haiti is sliding deeper into chaos
protesters have taken to the streets
after dozens of people were killed in a
week of gang violence
insecurity and unrest adding to a
spiraling economy that has never
completely recovered from a devastating
earthquake in 2010.
our situation is critical because we are
facing misery and hunger our children
can no longer go to school the
government is useless we demand its
departure it has to go
protesters blame the government for the
fuel crisis every time they want to
raise fuel prices they claim there's a
shortage it's not true there is stock
there's no need to cause people such
pain if they are determined to increase
prices we will set the country on fire
criminal gangs run the streets with
impunity police too weak to stop them
but this week anger and a loss of public
trust outweighed the fears of kidnapping
robbery injury and death
everyone must come together to revolt
children can't walk on the streets of
puerto prance we're tired we can't live
like this anymore let's rise up it's
difficult there's no way to live there
are bullets flying everywhere inside the
house we aren't safe and we can't go
outside
aid groups are struggling to provide
medical care to victims of stray bullets
and knife attacks the hallmarks of gang
violence but fighting hunger is perhaps
their biggest challenge
haiti has 1.3 million people
in emergencies so just before famine so
you've got
more than a million people that need
urgent assistance and if we're not able
to deliver urgent assistance
there is a
very great risk for that group so we're
very worried about that
haitians have been fleeing crushing
poverty for generations many to the
neighboring dominican republic or the
united states
as living conditions fail to improve the
number of people making perilous
journeys in search of food and safety is
likely to increase
zayn basravi al jazeera